the title of this talk is regional
climate projections and high resolution
economic modeling
so
uh let's see
there we go
so let me describe to you first i missed
one okay so the outline of the talk i'm
going to just describe a project i've
been working on for some time now
which is joint with pear crew cell in
stockholm a global economy climate model
with high regional resolution
okay now i'm not going to have time to
describe the whole model in
just 20 minutes
and this of course this uh this um
conference conferences about uncertainty
so i'm gonna i wasn't sure this talk
would fit in the theme of the conference
but what i want to focus on particular
is uh a down scaling model that we're
using to forecast regional temperature
and
uh and i would describe some uncertainty
i have about that and then maybe get
input from climate scientists about
about whether that's a
good a good way to proceed and i'll
explain why we're using that in a minute
okay so let me just describe the goals
of the project though so i'm very much
standing on the shoulders of bill
northhouse in fact that's literally true
since his office is directly below mine
so
uh so so a special case of this model is
the dice model so it looks like the dice
model is fully dynamic
optimizing consumers and so forth but
what we're introducing is heterogeneity
in a really big way plus some other
features
so we have a microeconomic foundation
like like dice does so we can evaluate
welfare but we're going to introduce a
very large number of regions
and in principle substantial
region-specific details so in a way it's
an attempt to get the economic models to
catch up heroically to what
the climate scientists are doing and
developing regional climate models
all right we're going to allow for
economic interactions between regions
for example capitals flows and insurance
and we're going to introduce uh this is
something somewhat new that i think
all three of these are somewhat new to
the literature spawned by dice
in particular we're also going to have
uncertainty or shocks the weather and
climate built into the model
and the goal the goal of this work is to
look at heterogeneity so a lot of the
discussion about climate change resolves
or it
revolves around who gains and who loses
in different parts of the world so we'd
like to use the model to measure
heterogeneous effects of climate change
and climate policy in an explicit
quantitative model right so there's also
rice if you're familiar with rice the
regional integrated climate economy
model that extends dice but maybe has
seven or eight very very large regions
we're going to go to
a very large number of much smaller
regions and then we can also use the
model to study things like heterogeneous
policy so if europe imposes a carbon tax
but no one else does what happens who
gains who loses i'm an explicit
quantitative economic model
and for those of you who have been
patiently listened to me discussed this
over the past couple years and slowly
make progress so at the point we've at
this point we've actually computed a
prototype version of this model
and the computational problem goes well
beyond it it turns out what we it was
harder than we thought it would be and
it goes well beyond what's been done in
macro so far it's only about 12 000
lines of code bill's going to tell me
that there are 12 errors in there but i
assure you they're tiny errors that
don't matter very much no actually
well um
not in my code yeah no anyway so then
policy policy analysis is up next
we haven't done that yet okay so this is
a quick overview of the mod i tried to
put on one slide because i'm not going
to discuss
this whole model and it's not going to
make sense or not economist anyway but
i'll just go through this so
like like like dice it has a
neoclassical production function using
three inputs capital labor and fossil
fuel
rather than have a representative agent
that represents the entire world or a
whole continent we have many small
regions there'll be about actually 20
000 of them in our analysis and each
region has a representative agent who
picks consumption investment and so
forth and decides to maybe borrow
internationally
labor can't move but capital can flow so
that's a spatial adaptation mechanism i
think is potentially important and
allows what's called leakage in response
to say differential carbon taxes in
different parts of the world
we have to solve for a world equilibrium
here and as a world market and risk-free
bonds and the world interest rate
adjusts to clear the markets and that's
where a lot of the hard work goes in
solving this model
we allow for stochastic fluctuations in
temperature and climate as i mentioned
they're going to be correlated in space
and time
so
a very very simple climate system and
carbon cyber even simpler than dice but
basically it's the usual story global
carbon emissions raise the global
temperature
and then there's and then that global
temperature feeds back into regional
temperature which then is plugged into
some kind of damage function okay and
there's heterogeneity and how regional
temperature varies with global warming
and and this is it's really this part
that i'm going to focus on in the talk
this is this is the part where i feel on
the least certain ground about what i'm
doing
okay so the calibration of the model so
unit of analysis there are about twenty
thousand one by one cells as in north
house's g-con database
so now i hit
uh command tab uh-oh
keep going
keep going to where
no
i have to do this all i see
yeah i thought apples were easy to use
okay just kidding uh
so this is
bill i don't know if this is on your
website anymore but i stole it a long
time ago
oh okay i wasn't sure you wouldn't want
people to see it anymore maybe maybe
there's a more recent version in any
case thanks for animating it this is not
i think i i know climate scientists are
great at showing lots of cool color
pictures and eventually i'll have a lot
of those but for right now this is all i
have this is actually bill's
construction this is these are the 19 20
000 little cells around the world over
land and blue colors are places where
there's not much economic activity and
warmer colors where there's a lot
and so for me a primitive unit here is a
little region and these regions are all
interacting through the climate system
through energy markets through financial
markets in a limited way
okay
and i want to study eventually what i'll
do is i'll animate this thing we could
do it now is i hadn't figured out the
technology of doing all the colors
eventually i could sort of animate a
dynamic evolution
of the of the world economy and you
could see temperature and gdp changing
and
through space and time okay
so now i get out of this and go back to
my
okay
back up
okay so now there's lots of things we
have to calibrate we've discussed them
all nice summary of all the places where
there's uncertainty their production
technology parameters preference
parameters governing discounting and
utility and so forth
damage functions in my case potentially
calibrated regionally and maybe
coastlines and different damage
functions at interior places the carbon
cycle model the forcing marble global
temperature
and then finally what's i think a new
element here and all in this kind of
type of modeling is this down scaling
model that'll be used it's not new to
the literature but it's new to being
used in economic models
it's not new to the climate science
literature
and so there's uncertainty about all of
these
to be honest i think we're doing almost
a better job here of worrying about
these things i know just the federal
reserve board when it runs its big macro
models worry as much as we are about
uncertainty i'm not about uncertainty at
the model and parameters i'm not so sure
i i think it's a worthy effort though um
anyway i'm going to focus mainly
on this on this down scaling model and
let me explain why i'm using it now okay
so i don't have anything to say about
the other
uncertainties
so i like this quote from richard
feynman
he says imagine how much harder physics
would be if electrons had feelings okay
that's why economics is way harder than
climate science okay
in the case we're
trying to get a rise out of you but in
any case
i'm not sure i really believe that but
there is a new element here which is
that if we think that agents
are sort of forward-looking and rational
i'm going to go to the extreme or
they're perfectly forward-looking
rational guys
then and then they're solving stochastic
dynamic programming problems so what do
they need to do they need to forecast
some kind of probability distribution
over future regional temperatures
because that's what affects damages in
their region
okay
but solving stochastic dynamic pruning
problems is hard the curse of
dimensionality
uh goes up exponentially with the
dimension of the state space
okay so there's no way i'm plugging in
one of these beautiful
gcms done at a regional level even if
you could run it fast enough which i
guess you can't i can't handle all those
state variables so i need to do
something simpler right unless i want to
abandon forward looking behavior i think
as a benchmark we should probably go
like i agree with bill to some extent
his benchmark let's go to the extreme
where all these guys are perfectly
forward-looking guys and they're
they're recognizing climate change in
the future and making changes now and
adapting their decisions to what might
happen in the future so the morals they
must severely limit the number of state
variables to forecast
to forecast temperature
so i'm going to go
now here's where i'm a little too brave
but at least there were two earlier
papers using econometric tools so i
don't know how to do gcm models and you
know i tried to read the output from
some websites all very complicated i
said well i know statistics i'm just
going to run my own
model here which it turns out i
discovered later is known as an
empirical statistical downscaling model
or a pattern scaling model i guess
sometimes in the literature so that so
that this is what i ran using historical
data so i got hold of uh matsuri and
wilmot's annual land temperature data
going back
sorry this is 1900 to 2008.
um i aggregated one by one cells and
then i estimated this model so
so what's what's the goal each region
wants to forecast its future regional
temperature i is for region i one of
these little cells and there's some kind
of long run average here or something
and then i guess i could use the pointer
and then there's the global temperature
and then there's a shock
okay and this is a sensitivity
coefficient l was latitude psi is an
unknown parameter so the idea is that
your regional sensitivity on average to
global climate change will vary by
latitude it's well known in climate
science but i'm going to reproduce
what's well known i guess using this
econometric model but what's key for me
is i'm actually going to put the shocks
in i'm going to come back to that i
realize that as i my question earlier
was related to the
using shocks
random shocks when fundamentally the
weather system apparently is not is not
driven by random shocks in the way that
our economic models are it's driven by a
chaotic chaotic dynamics well i'm just
going to pretend like it's just a random
shock out there
maybe it can proxy for things we don't
know but for right now just think about
it as
there's random variability in uh in the
cl
in your temperature so i'll allow these
shocks to be autocorrelated
okay i'll measure i'll estimate the auto
correlation coefficient
and there'll be some kind of innovation
variance here which governs how big an
average shock is
and then i'll allow these innovations in
this autoregressive process to be
correlated in space
and so this is the distance between
region i and region j and here's some
more parameters and so basically i've
estimated this then using my what i know
about econometrics estimated this big
system here so it's not unlike what was
done in some of the earlier um
talks that use econometrics so my
estimate is that the shocks are somewhat
autocorrelated 0.41 this is an annual so
if you're warm today your region will
tend to be warm tomorrow according to
the historical data and the shock is
pretty big it's 0.72
centigrade
degree centigrade that's the standard
deviation of a shock they look pretty
normal actually these shocks
all right this could be a lot of
measurement error i recognize that
there's a whole lot of interpolation
going on here especially for earlier
time periods and maybe what i'm picking
up partly here is interpolation errors
and calling them something structural in
any case so let me show you a couple
pictures that comes out of this then
i'll ask a few questions about my
downscaling model all right so it's a
very simple model this is my sufficient
statistic
global temperature and that's all i need
to know to predict my future mean
temperature but i know there'll be some
distribution around that because there's
randomness
okay
so here's just the global average land
temperature from my data okay we've seen
that a million times today
this is my this is my global temperature
that i'm feeding in as the as the
predictor i'm not feeding in the actual
variability but some kind of trend line
there's a couple pictures that i like
here that are new
uh this isn't so new this is my
these are my coefficients on sensitivity
coefficients to what latitude you're on
so
if you're at latitude minus 55 then when
the globe warms up by one degree
according to my estimates you are up by
one degree if you're at minus 25 you
warm up by less than a degree and so
forth you get more warming at the poles
uh less warming at the equator climate
scientists comment tell me this picture
doesn't look ridiculous
although
i think these should be maybe shifted a
little bit yeah go ahead but this is the
smooth response
i use a functional form i have a cubic
spline here there's a lot of variation
around here and i would expect that
because they're random shocks in my
model okay now my functional form could
be wrong and we could talk about that
but yeah yeah that's right yeah
okay now i also calculated the spatial
correlation of the shocks
and you can see that these are
temperature shocks so if you're very
nearby
you know you get a high correlation and
if you're far enough apart you get to
basically do a zero correlation if
you're 3 000 kilometers away that makes
sense okay so that that kind of makes
sense to me
and then this is kind of interesting
here i've been interested to get some
feedback on this now i've assumed so far
that the shocks have a constant variance
but now that i've estimated my model and
removed some of these trend terms i can
look at the properties of the shocks and
do a residual analysis
and really i should do another step and
re-estimate the model but let's just
take a residual do a residual analysis
so i'm going to imagine that maybe this
variance changes over time
okay it's not it's not in my model right
now it's not an either my structural
model or in this kind of metric model
neither i'm assuming it's going to be
constant but let's just look at a
residual
analysis allow it to vary by time and
estimate it so here are the estimates
you get
and this might be the l big el nino
event i guess people have told me one of
those two spikes but what you see here
so on average it's you know about point
seven right i if i constrain to be 0.7 i
get about here well it seems to be a
clear upward trend and a very noticeable
trend at the end there so i i think i
think it's like evidence actually that
shocks are getting bigger um i don't
know if this evidence is out there in
the literature
um i'd be curious to know and you know i
should give you standard errors and done
that yet so i mean there's
uncertainty development estimates okay
and then here's actually allowing now
the shock to ver this is showing
estimating a separate shock variance for
every data point so seeing whether some
latitude dependence and so you tend to
see that
areas and this is annual shocks the
areas near the equator tend to have
uh less variability and areas outside
tend to have more and that i think makes
sense as well so i think this is the
econometric this downscaling model is
picking up
you know the climate scientists aren't
going to laugh me out of the room
and probably they're more sophisticated
things have been done but the key thing
for me is i need to have
a small number of regressors small state
variables to be able to do so i could
handle a few more to be honest because
we developed some new methods but
not a whole lot more and i also want to
have a full shock structure there's a
lot of variability in the data and i
want to feed that into the model and
then i can ask questions you know about
maybe a global uh maybe climate change
leads to changes in mean temperature and
standard deviation of the temperature
now i can i can tell you like what are
the welfare effects of that who who
gains who loses
um okay so i only have two more slides
um because now i have a bunch of
questions about my downscaling model so
uh jeff hill earlier mentioned this
paper by hawkins and sutton
who quantify three sources of
uncertainty in regional climate
projections internal variability caused
by chaos
and uncertain and not knowing the
initial conditions precisely enough
model uncertainty or parameter
uncertainty even within the model i
would say and scenario uncertainty which
is emission scenarios you all know
so
i've kind of accounted for this one
already here this first internal
variability is i'm summarizing it with
the shock
i guess the shock is picking that up if
i simulate my model the global
temperature is not going to be smooth
it's going to move around because these
shocks you would think with nineteen
thousand regions and independent shocks
you wouldn't get very good but you
actually do because they're correlated
in space it adds up to something you
actually see the temperature moving
around
okay and that actually leads to
aggregate fluctuations
in my economic model which leads to a
lot of technical
complications i won't get into now
um
all right um and i guess the scenario
uncertainty is endogenized by the by the
model that's the point of the model so
it's no longer
something i need to vary independently
doesn't mean my model gives the right
path or emissions but what about the
downscaling model itself so first of all
even if you accept the functional form i
abstain
i don't know precisely the coefficients
that curve i drew you know has a
standard error around it how should i
capture that
should i
recognize that those parameters are
random variables
and stick them and stick that randomness
in the model so now the agents are
optimizing over
future distributions of coefficients in
that model and then if i do that i have
to do i then have to make them start
learning about the coefficients because
presumably they learn over time and
that's you know adding state variables
and complexity because now it makes the
forward-looking behavior even more
complicated
so these are just questions i have in my
mind like i worry that
you know what do i worry about this is
what i worry about in this part of the
model
now
what about uncertainty about the form of
the downscaling model maybe it's should
be non-linear i've actually looked a
little bit for that and maybe it should
have additional state variables or maybe
that should have a more complicated
error structure and
can i just capture that by just by
thinking of the shock maybe inflating
the shock and just calling that sort of
model uncertainty is that a way to the
proxy for that uncertainty i don't know
if that's legitimate or not
maybe one way of doing it i guess i
could look across a bunch of down
scaling models
and then calibrate the shock variants
which i'm calling now the shocks are now
natural variability but they could be
variability coming from not knowing what
the model is
ideally the agents would kind of update
some probability distribution over these
models using bayesian updating that may
be too complicated now this gets back to
a question from earlier about i almost
put sufficient statistics here which has
a precise meaning in statistics but
maybe a little less so here but
you know are there other state variables
besides the global mean temperature that
i could put into my
uh i could put into my model like i
don't know
average cloud cover or something or
average water content the atmosphere or
i don't if that's not a constant surely
maybe that's moving around uh the el
nino variation should that also be a
regressor my model
maybe because i'm not putting that in
i'm getting i'm finding auto-correlated
errors but that's actually more
predictable
so so i just feel like maybe there's
more i could put in here and
to be honest uh i could handle a few
more state variables there okay
um in that in this downscaling
relationship
and then finally the question that
worries me the most is
uh you know is this historical
downscaling relationship appropriate for
out-of-sample forecasting
and you know i'm
quite worried about sampling you know
projecting beyond the range of the data
that we've seen for temperatures we
haven't seen say
so i've explored a little bit using
ensembles of projections say
climateprediction.net
probably most of you know about that
here they're
it's like the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence they're
they're they're out there recruiting
people with free cycles on their
computers to run climate models and they
upload them
in a very non-digestible form at least
so far and maybe i could use those runs
to estimate the same down scaling
relationship
to plug into my model
and then feel more confident that i
that you know the physic
just this relationship may not hold out
of sample but what i really need would
need a lot of these runs because i
i think accounting for the errors in the
downscaling model are quite important
and you know for the optimization
problems based by consumers are quite
important so i would need you know i'd
love to have like 10 000 of these runs
varying maybe just initial conditions in
one set another set varying the model a
little bit
um
another set may be varying the uh the uh
the climate the emission scenario and
then somehow i could use all of those to
fit my impression is that i get maybe
100 runs or 10 runs
not really
uh maybe not enough runs to really fit
this kind of model i think it's
important to fit
that i that i've been able to fit with
historical data that's rich enough to
provide a good description of the
environment in which agents are behaving
okay so i guess i'm out of time so
that's that's the that's the so that's
the uncertainty i care about the most
right now i'm worried about the most
because i know the least about it
there's a lot of discussion of climate
sensitivity and all that i know less
about this
and
i
i
i hope to have you know policy analysis
coming out of this rather shortly so
look for it on my website at some point
okay thank you very much